Olá você já se pegou bocejando depois de
ver alguém bocejar é fascinante não é eu
sou D aland Dutra médico há mais de 25
anos e hoje vou falar sobre um hábito
tão simples e natural mas que tem algo
intrigante por trás se você já ouviu
falar no bocejo contagiante sabe do que
eu estou falando basta uma pessoa
bocejar ao seu lado para que você logo
sinta aquela Irresistível vontade de
bocejar também e a coisa fica ainda mais
curiosa estudos mostram que esse efeito
é mais forte entre amigos próximos e
familiares e ainda tem uma conexão bem
interessante entre bocejar e nossos
amigos de quatro patas os cães é como se
estivéssemos conectados de alguma forma
pesquisas também investigam as teorias
do porqu bocejamos e o que isso pode nos
dizer sobre nossa saúde eu vou
compartilhar alguns insights sobre o que
a ciência diz a respeito mas antes
prepare-se porque você pode acabar
bocejando enquanto Assiste esse vídeo
olha só que curioso a maioria das
pessoas boceja pelo menos uma ou duas
vezes quando ouve falar sobre bocejo
quando chegar ao final me conta nos
comentários Quantas vezes você bocejou
assistindo esse vídeo você sabia que
bocejar é algo que a gente faz antes
mesmo de nascer pessoal estudos com
imagens de ultrassom capturam bebês
bocejando ainda no útero e apesar de
muitas vezes associarmos o bocejo ao
tédio sono ou cansaço pesquisas recentes
sugerem que há muito mais acontecendo do
que a gente imagina esse comportamento
simples é involuntário como respirar e
parece ter múltiplos gatilhos cientistas
divergem quanto ao motivo principal do
bocejo alguns acreditam que ele tem
causas fisiológicas e benefícios físicos
claros e quantos outros defendem que sua
origem é mais psicológica funcionando
até como meio de comunicação sabemos no
entanto que todos os humanos e muitos
animais bocejam O interessante é que o
bocejo excessivo como bocejar mais de
uma vez por minuto pode ser sinal de
exaustão ou até de um problema médico
algumas pesquisas indicam que o excesso
de bocejo pode estar ligado a condições
que elevam a temperatura cerebral como
lesões no sistema nervoso central vale a
pena ficar atento ao bocejo quando ele é
inexplicável e constante especialmente
se você também sente muito sono durante
o dia pode ser um sinal de resposta vaso
vagal que é causada pela demora na
chegada de Sangue ao coração e ao
cérebro pode indicar também um problema
no nevo vago ou até mesmo um possível
ataque cardíaco condições como epilepsia
tumores cerebrais ou doenças autoimunes
como esclerose múltipla também podem
estar envolvidas uma disfunção do fígado
mais séria como insuficiência hepática
pode causar bjos excessivos assim como
problemas na regulação da temperatura
corporal como ocorre com o
hipotiroidismo não tratado e até mesmo
alguns medicamentos podem causar Esse
aumento na frequência do bocejo portanto
embora o bocejo possa ser algo simples e
comum ele pode estar nos dizendo mais
sobre nossa saúde do que
imaginamos agora Vamos explorar algumas
pesquisas e teorias por trás do bocejo
uma das teorias mais populares é a
superficialidade da respiração A ideia é
que quando respiramos de forma
superficial menos oxigênio entra na
corrente sanguínea e o corpo provoca o
bocejo para inspirar mais ar e aumentar
os níveis de oxigênio e se você v seja
quando está entediado há uma explicação
para isso também o tédio pode deixar
nossa respiração superficial reduzindo
os níveis de oxigênio no sangue e
aumentando o dióxido de carbono bocejar
ajuda a renovar o oxigênio e remover o
dióxido de carbono são muitas as teorias
e pesquisas sobre esse comportamento
fascinante o que está claro é que o
bocejo vai muito além do simples Cansaço
ou Tédio e pode oferecer insights
valiosos sobre o funcionamento do nosso
corpo
pessoal tudo isso é muito interessante
mas há uma teoria ainda mais convincente
desenvolvida pelo pesquisador Andrew
gallop e seus colegas na universidade de
princeton ele sugere que o bocejo ajuda
a resfriar o cérebro Especialmente
quando estamos cansados ou com privação
de sono durante um bocejo a boca se abre
os pulmões expiram mais ar os tímpanos
se esticam e às vezes os olhos se
com força provocando até lágrimas esses
movimentos ativam um aumento na
frequência cardíaca e no fluxo sanguíneo
nos músculos faciais ajudando a resfriar
o cérebro cada um desses mecanismos
contribui para a capacidade do corpo de
regular a temperatura cerebral no
entanto resfriar o cérebro é apenas uma
das explicações possíveis outra teoria
sugere que o bocejo ocorre durante
mudanças de estado no corpo pode ser
mais frequente quando estamos entediados
sonolentos ou após atividades físicas
intensas todas essas situações
representam uma transição que o cérebro
e o corpo precisam gerenciar até
mudanças de altitude podem provocar
bocejos como a maneira de aliviar o
acúmulo de ar nos tímpanos ao bocejar o
tímpano se alonga expandindo as trompas
de Eustáquio para equalizar a pressão
atrás dos ouvidos e aliviar desconfortos
esse fenômeno conhecido como barotrauma
de ouvido pode ser minimizado
bocejando pessoal como eu já mencionei
muitas vezes o bocejo pode ser um sinal
de cansaço ele pode surgir antes de
dormir ou logo ao acordar pela manhã a
privação de sono e a exaustão podem
elevar a temperatura cerebral acima do
ideal para seu funcionamento correto uma
das várias funções do sono é a
termorregulação e equilibrando a
liberação e Distribuição de calor para
manter uma temperatura corporal saudável
a termorregulação pode ser entendida
como um conjunto de mecanismos que
permitem regular a temperatura corporal
interna de forma a mantê-la dentro de
valores compatíveis com a vida quando a
temperatura do meio externo varia agora
com o sono adequado nosso corpo consegue
encontrar esse equilíbrio mas noites mal
dormidas dificultam a regul ação térmica
fazendo o cérebro
superaquecer O que leva ao cansaço
bocejar pode ser uma tentativa do corpo
de compensar essa falha na
termorregulação causada pela falta de
sono nesse caso o gatilho do bocejo pode
não ser a falta de oxigênio no cérebro
mas a má regulação da temperatura
cerebral a ciência já observou em
estudos com ratos privados de sono que
suas temperaturas cerebrais eram
ligeiramente mais altas do que suas
temperaturas corporais centrais além
disso eles apresentaram metabolismo
reduzido na região do cérebro que
controla a temperatura e as glândulas
endócrinas pessoal parece que bocejar
pode ser mais do que um reflexo do
cansaço ou tédio pode ser uma tentativa
do corpo de nos ajudar a manter a cabeça
fria literalmente
você já reparou como bocejo é Contagioso
aquele momento em que você vê alguém
bocejar e de ente Você também está
bocejando junto com outras pessoas ao
seu redor Esse é o famoso bocejo
Contagioso pesquisas revelam que a
probabilidade de sermos contagiados está
relacionada ao nosso vínculo com a
pessoa que iniciou a bocejo a resposta
mais forte ocorre entre familiares
seguida de amigos próximos conhecidos e
por último estranhos esse efeito Foi
confirmado em estudos que sugerem que o
bocejo Contagioso é mais intenso quanto
maior a proximidade emocional entre as
pessoas envolvidas a empatia pode ser um
fator chave aqui mostrando que estamos
mais propensos a pegar o bocejo daqueles
com quem temos uma ligação afetiva em
estranhos essa resposta é mais fraca
mostrando que a familiaridade a conexão
social desempenham um papel nesse
fenômeno curioso pessoal os mesmos os
pesquisadores que estudaram a relação
entre respiração termorregulação e
bocejo Contagioso realizaram
experimentos fascinantes sobre esse
comportamento eles descobriram que a
maneira como respiramos pode influenciar
se bocejamos ou não após ver outra
pessoa bocejando Por exemplo quando os
participantes foram instruídos a
respirar pela boca 48% deles bocejar ao
ver outros bo
No entanto quando orientados a respirar
apenas pelo nariz de forma mais natural
e controlada nenhum dos participantes
apresentou bocejos contagiosos Além
disso os pesquisadores também exploraram
a teoria da
termorregulação aplicando bolsas de
temperatura na testa dos participantes
enquanto assistiam a um vídeo de pessoas
bocejando ao segurarem uma bolsa morna
na testa o sejo Contagioso ocorreu em
41% dos casos quando a bolsa era fria no
entanto a incidência caiu para apenas
99% isso sugere que o bocejo pode ser
funcional em relação à temperatura e que
está conectado à nossa capacidade de
regular a temperatura do cérebro você já
bocejou e notou que seu animal de
estimação como seu cachorro ou gato
também bocejou logo em seguida responda
nos comentários se isso já aconteceu com
você e seu seu amigo peludo Olha que
interessante pessoal estudos mostram que
chimpanzés cães babuínos e Lobos também
experimentam bocejos contagiosos entre
membros do grupo Só que no caso dos cães
é mais provável que eles bocejam após
verem os seus donos bocejar em vez de
imitarem outro cão um estudo investigou
esse comportamento envolvendo 29 cães
observando como eles reagiam a humanos
jando para comparar um grupo de controle
foi incluído onde humanos faziam outros
movimentos com a boca que não eram
bocejos o resultado mostrou que quase
73% dos cães bocejar após ver os humanos
bocejando enquanto o grupo de controle
que fez Movimento Sem bocejo não
influenciou o comportamento dos cães
isso sugere que o bocejo Contagioso pode
estreitar o vínculo entre você e seu
animal de estimação talvez ajudando a
aumentar a conexão e a coordenação entre
vocês um estudo publicado na biology
letters sugere que como você modula os
níveis de citação o contágio do bocejo
pode facilitar a comunicação e a
interação entre humanos e cães outra
pesquisa descobriu que os cães são mais
propensos a bocejar a ouvir um bocejo de
alguém familiar como seus donos em vez
de
desconhecidos Isso mostra que os cães
não imitam qualquer humano mas são mais
afetados
por quem compartilha um vínculo
emocional embora os pesquisadores ainda
não possam tirar conclusões definitivas
sobre como o bocejo Contagioso funciona
nos cães esses estudos já oferecem
evidências de que esse comportamento
pode estar ligado à empatia e à conexão
emocional entre os animais e seus donos
compartilhe os vos bem a vida de alguém
pode mudar também no canal
do
alvar Espero que você tenha gostado
desse tema curioso Muito obrigado pela
sua atenção um grande abraço um beijo no
seu coração Você é fera